في التطورات الميدانيه للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا قال مكتب المدعي العام الاوكراني
ان شخصين قتل اوصيب 10 اخرون في قصف
نورسين على مدينه تيهارنك في دونتسك وفي
المقابل قالت السلطات الانفصاليه المواليد
لروسيا ان المقاطعه تتعرض لقصف اوكراني
المركز او قاع اربعه قتلى وسبعه جرحه وفي
خلصنا جنوب اوكرانيا قالت سلطات المقاطعه
ان شخصين قتل اصيب سبعه اثر قصف روسي على
احد الاحياء السكنيه في المدينه افاده
مراسل الجزيره في المقاطعه باشتداد حده
القتال بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
على طول ضفتي نهر معنى من خير سنه ماضي
مراسل الجزيره ومن دونالدز السلام خضر من
هناك ابدا بسلام خضر هل نحن اذا تصعيد غير
معتاد في وتيره القصف والقذف المتبادل
زين على مدى الاسبوع الماضي نعم شهدت
الجبهات تصعيدا يمكن ان نصفه بانه غير
مسبوق خاصه في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه
ما هو غير مسبوق التصعيد الاوكراني تجاه
قصف او استهداف مناطق داخل مدينه دانيت
طبعا مدينه توصف بانها عاصمه الانفصلين
وان تبقى هذه المدينه تحت اا وطاه القصف
الاوكراني فهذا هو التصعيد الجديد ربما في
سير الامور منذ شباط فبراير الماضي وسط
المدينه لا يزال يتعرض للقذف اعداد القتلى
ارتفعت بسقوط كثير اضافه في استهداف جديد
لاحد الاسواق التجاريه ظهرها هذا اليوم في
مدينه دمياط هذا على صعيد المدينه على
الصعيد جبهات القتال القتال مستمر وهو
يشتد بين حين واخر قبل قليل كان بتاعك
استهداف همم
مكثف من قبل الجانب الروسي على بعض
المواقع الاوكرانيه المتمركزه عند اطراف
دونياتسك تحديدا عند جنوب دانياتك القوات
الروسيه تقول انها تتقدم في اتجاه الجنوب
من دون ان تحدد المناطق التي تتقدم اليها
شمال دنياست ايضا هناك تقدم بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ومن اعلن عن هذا التقدم هو
الرئيس المؤقت ل همم الموالي لروسيا هنا
في دانيت قال ان القوات الروسيه قد
استطاعت التقدم بنحو السبعين بالمئه من
منطقه مريم ويتوقع الرجل بان يتم السيطره
عليها في غضون ساعات كما قال ولكن حصيله
العمليات القتاليه بالنسبه للجانب الروسي
نستمع اليها في كلام المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ايجار
وصلت القوات الروسيه عمليتها الهجوميه
نتيجه للاشتباك الوقائي تم احباط محاوله
العدوش ان هجوم مضاد على المواقع الروسيه
في اتجاه البيسكي في جمهوريه الشعبيه
وبلغت خسائر الجانب الاوكراني 30 جنديا
كما دمر الطيران التشغيل والتكتيكي
والقوات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه وحدات
المدفعيه الثالثه والثمانين التابعه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في مواقع اطلاق
النار وفي منطقه تم تدميره مستودع ذخيره
تابعي لواء الدفاع الاقليمي 202 التابعي
للقوات الاوكرانيه بالقرب من قريه بول في
منطقه زمولوجيا
شكرا جزيلا لك السلام خضر تامر حسني
حول منطقه خيرسون ما الذي يقول الجانب
الاوكراني عن هذا القصف وايضا عن همم
محاولات همم التقدم نحو دوناتس
نعم هازين بالفعل القصف اليوم في خرسون
كان على اشدها المدينه كانت تحت وابل من
القصف والقذف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه بالمدفعيه تحديدا على
ضفتين ارض نيبر تواجد الان في احد اخطر
الاحياء ان صح لي تعبير لان هذا الحي مطل
تماما على ضفه نهر دنيبر او على نهر دنيبر
من الجانب الاوكراني وفي هذا الحي قبل
قليل اعلنت السلطات المحليه عن مقتل شخصين
واصابه سبعه اخرين في صفوف المدنيين وذلك
لان بنايه سكنيه اصيبت ب همم المدفعيه
الروسيه خلال الدقائق الاخيره القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول بانها تكثف بالفعل من
قصفها لمواقع تواجد القوات الروسيه عند
الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر بالمناسبه زين
هذه القوات الروسيه كانت انسحبت من قلب
المدينه خير قبل اكثر من اسبوعين بعدما
استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه المدينه
وانسحبت الضفه الاخرى اعين ال- ال- الجيش
الاوكراني كما يقول هي موجهه باتجاه الضفه
الاخرى يريد ان يبعد القوات
الروسيه المتواجده خارج حدود منطقه خيرسون
ريف خيرسون من الجهه الاخرى يقول بانه
بالفعل يكثف من قصفه لتلك المواقع يتحدث
عن قتلى وجرحى يتحدث عن خسائر في صفوف
القوات الروسيه هناك ويقول ايضا بانه يضرب
خطوط الامداد بين تلك المناطق على الضفه
الاخرى من النهر
وشبه جزيره القرم يقول بان القوات الروسيه
تحاول ايصال العتاد خلال الايام الماضيه
لكن المفارقه اليوم انه تحدث عن انسحاب
بعض القطاعات للقوات الروسيه من ضفه النهر
وقال بانه رصد ايضا انسحاب لعدد من
الاليات في اتجاه الشرق شرق اوكرانيا حيث
تدور معارك طاحنه هنالك اكثر فاكثر القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول انها خلال يومين الماضيين
ايضا سي على عدد من الجزر ال- ال- التي
كانت يعني رماديه لم يكن يسيطر عليها ال-
ال- الاوكران ولا الروس داخل نهر دنيبر
جزر صغيره واستولت عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه وتقول بانها يعني تو يعني
تواصل عمل المزيد من العمليات العسكريه من
اجل ابعاد القوات الروسيه باتجاه مناطق
اكثر فيها اكثر ال- ال- الوضع الانساني في
المدينه السيء للغايه لا خدمات لا كهرباء
لاما واا الدعوات متواصله للسكان لضروره
الاخلاء الفوري للمدينه هنا هنا